objectif assurer leur sécurité les cinq
agents et bientôt six de la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux vont
recevoir d'ici quelques mois une
formation pour l' usage de pistolets à
impulsion électrique
un équipement plus pour répondre
également aux nouvelles menaces depuis
les attentats par exemple je demande à
mes policiers de faire des fouilles aux
entrées aux entrées des établissements
publics lorsqu'il ya une manifestation
aujourd'hui quelque part ils sont assez
démunis s'il devait être attaqués dans
ce contexte là par exemple comme il
porte l'uniforme c'est vrai que ce sont
des cibles potentielles dont
l'opposition municipale les avis
divergent quant à l'armement des agents
si à gauche jean h estime que la
démarche va trop loin à droite en
revanche les taser sont jugés
insuffisants
un nouveau débat que refuse alexandra
rosetti ce qui me gêne beaucoup dans les
raisonnements d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a le sentiment qu'on attend beaucoup
plus de deux missions qui ne sont pas
les leurs pour lesquelles ils ne sont
pas formés
on a une police nationale pour ça on a
des unités spéciales et je pense qu'il
ya une grosse confusion en ce moment
c'était une confusion des genres
l'arrivée des pistolets à impulsion
électrique ne devrait pas être
officielle avant fin 2010 est
l'installation de 15 nouvelles caméras
de vidéo surveillance est également
prévue